how much did marvel have
everything figured out in terms of the
sitcoms and ultimately the arc of the
entire thing and how much
is it how much were they asking you you
know what i mean for that back and forth
it was a real collaboration which is i
think
one of the great things about working at
marvel i mean it's a brilliantly
creative place
all the people there are so fabulous and
and smart
and you know they we build these things
as we go and a show like one division
that's a real
puzzle box required that as you build
forward towards the end you have to stop
as you figure things out and go back and
rework the beginning and then keep going
and so that was that was very much our
prep process was kind of figuring out
all of the intricate parts of this
narrative and making sure it all worked
really well
uh you obviously had an extended
shutdown due to covid
and a lot of people i think benefit from
having more time in the editing room
and i'm curious how did the extended
shutdown
possibly shift how the entire series
went or did you make any changes
as a result of having more time with the
footage it was interesting
i think in the end we probably had about
the same amount of time in post as we
would have otherwise because when
we finally did get back to production we
were so close to our air gate anyway
that our post production on the other
side of that
you know finishing shooting was was
short and truncated but yeah we
we used every bit of time that we had um
to get the shows into as good of shape
as they could possibly be and
certainly you know um we we learned some
things in the editing room that we were
able to tinker with when we went back to
shooting
uh i know the series is nine episodes
have you are you completely done with
all nine
uh no we are not completely done with
all of them got it so you're still doing
vfx on some of the last ones
we are yeah yep sound mixing finishing
score that kind of stuff yeah i kind of
figured so
um i want to confirm is the entire
series if you were to watch it from
beginning to end
is it six hours what's the length of the
entire thing
yeah roughly around six hours i know the
first three episodes are about 30
minutes each
at some point i guess some of these
episodes are going to start being
what like an hour like how long are some
of these upcoming episodes
yeah i mean i'll let you guys sort of
discover that as you go i mean so much
of one division
is narrative through form manipulation
you know we are playing around with
aspect ratio and size and episode length
and style and design so there's a lot to
discover kind of as you go along
okay so you're saying to me that there
could be an episode down the road that
is an hour and a half
or something longer i am doing what i
what i what i usually do is just say
nothing
okay i get that uh did you end up with a
lot
because now i'm realizing [ __ ] maybe
there's a two-hour episode at the end
and i'm not even thinking i didn't even
think about that um uh
did you end up with a lot of deleted
scenes and are there any plans to put
them on disney plus
gosh i i don't know we haven't really
discussed any sort of outtakes or
or that uh you know what to do with
anything we did eliminate yeah you know
every process along the way there are
those scenes where um that things get
trimmed and
stuff gets removed but yeah i'm not sure
let me let me do the follow-up and say
are there a lot of deleted scenes
or is it just like a few minor things
here and there
gosh i don't know you know it's i mean
there's nothing major you know little
things along the way
you know pacing clarifying things here
and there yeah
uh in the 80s sitcom episode did you
purposely make a full house reference
well i couldn't possibly say anything
yet about any of that
got it man you've been trained well
um uh how much
is it when people watch it again after
they've seen the finale
will they be watching the first episode
and being like oh my god it was there
the whole time
i think there certainly are um easter
eggs and
bits of puzzle pieces along the way that
that when you watch it again you will
see more um i think any good story
movie the ending has to be both
surprising and
inevitable you have to feel like it was
set up really well and so that was
definitely our goal here
and i think hopefully if you watch it
again you will you'll see how it was
built
it recently came out that loki might be
get like loki they might be doing a
second season of loki
obviously this series ties into doctor
strange too
and there's a lot more to this but has
there been any conversations about
possibly doing something like a second
season of one division
or is this always been planned as like a
one and a one-off
i have no idea about the future you know
in
in the marvel world in the mcu the end
is often not the end
who knows hard to say got it uh there
are commercials
really fun commercials in the first
three episodes
how much are these commercials sort of
for the fans and how much are these
commercials actually time like
you should be paying attention because
these tie into the bigger thing
gotcha i mean i would hate to answer
that with with too much specificity
um you know everything in the show is
important to the show and to the
storytelling
got it uh well let's switch gears and
say was there anything when you guys
were making the series
that you battled over and uh
and why is this an interview or a
deposition
um no
you must know collider and you know that
i'm trying to dig for things that
i can you know the people want to know
that's not just like tell me what it was
like
working with elizabeth olsen yeah yeah i
hear you no i applaud you they're very
good questions um
uh no i mean we had a great
collaboration um uh jack shaper and i
had a great time working together
all of our designers uh you know
cinematographer the production team is
amazing many of whom i've worked with
before
all of whom i would be desperate to work
with again and the actors
are amazing at the risk of you know
breaking down and singing kumbaya
which i really will do um is you know
the they're all wonderful
we had the best time and i think you
know part of of the joy of making the
show is that when you're when you're
doing so many different tones and styles
you just have to be fearless and you
have to trust everybody
hold everyone's hand and just take the
jump you know and i think they were all
willing to do that and it was just
it was so much fun because of that uh
this was obviously your first time
working with marvel
uh i'm curious did you look did you talk
to any of the previous marvel directors
for like sort of input or guidance on
like you know how they did their thing
because one of the things that i commend
marvel is that they're always bringing
in
new people with fresh takes and i i love
it
yeah you know marvel is a very open
community so i did have conversations
with
other filmmakers all of whom i admire
tremendously
and you know even when i was assembling
uh team
you know for for you know production
designer et cetera all those guys who
definitely talked to other directors
about people that they had worked with
um in that process and then when we have
sort of narrative
questions as well you know um we we do
tend to talk talking to we end up
talking to each attend
to talk to each other about how those uh
stories will
pick up from what's been done and how
they'll hand off
completely um are you doing the
cambridge analytica movie
ah no unfortunately not you know um that
movie
uh is it was a great script and a great
story but
a bit of a tiny movie to be done during
covet and
covet ended up kind of derailing it
because you know the cost of producing
things during this right now is so big
that
i just and it also i think sadly or
maybe not sadly maybe
for a good reason its time seems to have
passed a little bit because
you know how trump got elected in 2016
is obviously less relevant than what it
how it might have been if it had come
out
as planned in the fall of 2020. got it i
got to stop
i'm just going to say i hope i get to
talk to you again after i've seen the
finale
and we can get into specifics that would
be great thank you very much